m
[Applaudissements]
nicolas à rennes 2 août des moules ça
c'était mon père quand je venais tout
juste de commencer à apprendre à jongler
j'avais 18 ans et j'avais la fougue de
la jeunesse à cette époque
une chose était sûre pour moi j'allais
être jongleurs non mais franchement vous
croyez que ça motive
qu'est-ce que c'était dur à entendre moi
j'aurais plutôt préféré entendre c'est
bien ce que tu fais vas-y continues tu
me régale les années ont passé
j'ai fini par en faire mon métier bon
enfin pour être honnête j'ai deux
métiers
je suis développeur d'applications
informatiques et jongleurs mais malgré
ça j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à cette phrase
nicolas et un jour miracle j'avais enfin
compris ce que mon père voulait me dire
ils voulaient tout simplement mener en
m'offrant une nouvelle piste de travail
il me suggérait d'essayer de jongler
avec de nouveaux objets et grâce à ce
merveilleux conseil
j'ai décidé de créer un laboratoire de
curiosité artistique dédié à la création
de nouveaux objets pour jongleurs
femmes ces mondes rhône c'est le premier
objet que j'ai voulu fabriquer
fabriquer des drones pour jongler et
bien évidemment cette idée était
extrêmement facile à réaliser
bah oui surtout ici en nouvelle
calédonie on trouve des magasins de
pièces détachées pour drones de partout
bon bah du coup j'ai tout commandé par
correspondance j'ai attendu quelques
semaines j'ai reçu mes pièces chez
maupéou drones jeu le départ et il va
brûler du coup je recommande les pièces
nouveau rebondissement
une pièce est défaillante et savait
oblige
je recommande la pièce est au bout de
trois mois
à force d'attendre mes pièces
me voilà avec quoi bein ça un culbuto
géant
[Musique]
et
à
m
non
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
et
hautmont
[Musique]
imaginez la surprise dans mon entourage
j'annonce que je vais utiliser des
drones et je montre des culbutes audio 1
avance ses prêts tu nous montres 5 ans
ça c'est la pression exercée par mon
entourage
depuis le début de la création d'un
laboratoire bon faut dire que je vais un
peu cherché j'ai travaillé pendant plus
d'un an sur une multitude d'objets sans
jamais rien montré
et durant cette année
j'ai été très seul j'ai été seul à samé
idée j'ai été seul à samé échec
j'ai été seul à son temps qui défile et
surtout j'étais seul face à mes doutes
et mon envie de tout plaquer
[Musique]
pour
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
non
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à jongler tardivement
j'avais 18 ans j'étais étudiant en
informatique et j'étais inscrit à
l'école de cirque tous les jours
j'allais à la fac et tous les jours
gérer à l'école de cirque et puis le
mois de décembre est arrivé
bonjour nicolas c'est papa alors comment
se sont passé des examens
plutôt bien je suis assez content aulas
cauchemar j'avais pas renoncé à mon papa
que j'avais arrêté mes études j'étais
hyper mal à l'aise j'avais peur de sa
réaction
bah oui il a fait une brillante carrière
d'ingénieur agronome il a passé sa vie à
faire des hybridations les croisements
entre les espèces et puis le mois de mai
est arrivé j'étais face au mur je
pouvais plus
je devais lui dire la vérité papa tu
sais ça fait six mois que j'ai arrêté
mes études mais c'est pas grave je vais
faire jongleurs arènes de nîmes des
moules au passage juste une question à
méditer pour qu il était un peu plus dur
pour mon papa qui souhaitait que son
fils fasse de brillantes études ou bien
pour moi qui n'a jamais eu le soutient
dans sa passion du cirque mais tu devais
faire ça en cachette
[Musique]
en tout cas
si jamais un jour je dois arrêter mes
études au moins j'ai rien à craindre
ah oui j'ai fait des études d'ingénieur
et une chose est sûre c'est que vous ne
me verrez jamais fabriqué des objets
inutiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et si je faisais un spectacle tu
mélanges rem et de compétence ingénieur
et jongleurs et je l'appellerai
hybridation et oui ce sera un croisement
issue mes deux passions et en plus ce
sera un clin d'oeil à mon papa tu vois
moi aussi papa
j'en fais des hybridations
[Applaudissements]